let's talk about the the bit of a reset
I think going on in the world with covet
I've been asking for it for a long time
I see in Europe a lot of the leaders are
now saying we have to live with it Boris
Johnson said it we have to live with it
it's not going away
treat it like the flu some of the things
they're doing in the UK now that they're
not doing anymore they're ending
mandated fat face masks masks in school
that's gone work from home advisories
nope mandatory passports to get into
nightclubs and large events legal
requirement to self-isolate no
we're getting they're getting back to
normal
we should follow this I think what do
you think
should I leave it to the congressman I
think we've been gradually transitioning
to normal I mean the public health
response has become less Draconian and
more measured over time as the pandemic
has become more manageable and that's
because of the success of the
vaccination campaign the Biden
Administration has presided over the
vaccination of more than 200 million
Americans which has been effective
but now that you're okay I'm done
[Applause]
I went so hard on kovid I yeah I
remember braid the Pringles cans that I
bought at the grocery store stripped my
clothes off because I thought kovid
would be on my clothes like I did it all
I watched Tiger King I got to the end of
Spotify like we all did it right
no no we did not do it well here's the
thing a lot of us did do it and then we
were told you get the vaccine you get
the vaccine and you get back to normal
and
we haven't gotten back to normal and
it's ridiculous at this point
I know that so many of my liberal and
Progressive friends are with me on this
and they do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be called
anti-vaxx or to be called science denial
or to be you know smeared as a Trumper
I'm sorry if you believe the science you
will look at the data that we did not
have two years ago and you will find out
that cloth masks do not do anything you
will realize that you can show your
vaccine passport at a restaurant and
still be asymptomatic in carrying
Omicron and you will realize most
importantly that this is going to be
remembered by the younger generation as
a catastrophic moral crime
the city of Flint Michigan which is 80 I
think minority students has just
announced indefinite virtual schooling
in the past two years we've seen among
young girls a 51 increase in self-harm
people are killing themselves they are
anxious they are depressed they are
lonely that is why we need to end it
more than any inconvenience that it's
been to the rest of us I think
okay
it's like at this point it's a pandemic
of bureaucracy it's a pandemic of
bureaucracy it's not it's not real
anymore let's not forget that you know
the pandemic has left the death count of
more than 850 000 Americans well that's
a yes but it was a description it was a
blunt instrument okay if you look at who
was affected by this 803 children have
died in the past two years in the entire
country from and with because I offer
perspective in I was a New Yorker who
lived through the early weeks and early
months of the pandemic and it was just a
catastrophe for New York City the likes
of which we've never seen we saw
overflowing emergency rooms uh New York
lost more than 60 000 people the Bronx
Alone lost more than seven thousand
people which is larger than the combined
death toll of Pearl Harbor and 911 I saw
Mass Graves and heart Island in the
Bronx I mean most New Yorkers saw a
level of death and suffering we've never
seen in our lives and that's the source
of the concern about covet I mean I
reject the notion that the response to
covet has been worse than the disease
itself
well
I would argue with that
I mean I have I asked for the covert
deaths by state
this is per hundred thousand people the
worst is Mississippi
my home state in New Jersey four
th worst
New York's sixth worst
West Virginia and Massachusetts are 10
and 11.
right together
could there be two states who are more
unalike right then West Virginia and
Massachusetts and the poster boy for
keeping open was Florida they're
down at 17.
so New York and New Jersey did worse
than Florida
what I'm saying is we did worse because
we're a densely populated Hub of
international travel Florida should have
done more Florida is home to all the old
people in America so maybe they should
have done it but the dot is crystal
clear and this is beyond dispute that
the deaths and hospitalizations have
been overwhelmingly concentrated among
the unvaccinated if you are fully
vaccinated yes you have a far lower risk
of infection and hospitalization and
death but that's not even the issue
we're talking about now we will get to
it
what this is saying is Florida like
stayed open I mean I I was just in
Florida I've been there a few times
since this started New York has moved
there
hair is just different I'm not moving to
Florida I'm not promoting Florida I'm
just saying AOC just went to Florida and
had a good time without a mask okay
I'm just saying I've been to Florida the
atmosphere was just night and day from
California which was gloomy and
everything was the The Andromeda Strain
was out there and you went to FL and you
went to Florida and I'm just saying yes
there are different factors and
differences but basically it's like they
stayed open and went on with life and
they didn't do a hell of a lot worse and
maybe did better